we talk about this a lot on bright ideas
it's like when you go away on a trip
with someone for the first time how's
that going to work out where are you
going to I know what you do what do
you do I'd probably say hey the pool
looks really sweet why don't you head
out to the pool I gotta take care of a
few things interesting hey I'm gonna go
check with the front desk I'll be back I
want to see if they have any massages
and then pow
and then you know come back and go
you're like what about the massages like
oh they weren't there what if they want
to go with you see that no no no no no
you stay you you stay there I want to
take care of this I want to surprise you
well it's not a surprise anymore you
already told me I know but I just wanted
something I have to do on my own all
right I gotta take a
it's a thing man it's a thing